welders
how did how did you do this call in a
few favors excuse me a few hundred
favors Mr Vice President Ben Wyatt from
Congressman Murray's office and Dave
told me you're going to be coming by and
you must be Leslie no welcome welcome
my my name just came out of your mouth
well yeah it did
look this isn't happening
this isn't real no it's it's happening
and I'm delighted to have you here on
behalf of the president myself Mr Vice
President I am deeply flattered but
there's no way that I could take over
Madame secretary Clinton's position I
mean I'm confident you could do that job
or any other but okay I will well the
reason you're here is I'm told you've
done such a great job in your town in
the state of Indiana and I just want to
say congratulations for your public
service I just want to say thank you
well you you are very welcome you're
very welcome hi you're you're very
welcome
you're very handsome well you're very
nice thank you thank you thank you very
much thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow
you will
thank you Mr Vice President you're
welcome you don't let anything happen to
him you understand me
he's Precious Cargo you guys it's like
we're in high school and we're at the
cool table right yeah and were you a
cheerleader no she was told a little
Miss artsy fartsy in high school she
wore the turtleneck and everything
that's hilarious
hilarious
where'd you go to school Bishop O'Hara
his slob who cares uh we played you
you really look familiar did you uh you
cheered for them didn't you um
yes I did
a-w-e-s-o-m-e awesome awesome is what we
are we're the football Superstars
we crushed you like 42-10
[Music]
that'll ever be us
what is wrong with you why did you even
bring me here tonight
I don't know
let's break up
whoa what I have 85 do I have 90. I have
90 from the man with the face at table
four it's just terrible
you don't know what you're doing Adam
Sandler yeah that's right I collect
Antiquities I'm a serious person I'm
writing a movie right now about the
Russian Revolution oh really who does
Kevin James play in it it's a serious
movie
Trotsky ah there it is but he's got a
wife who never wears a bra I think
you're gonna like it
thanks for dressing up by the way all
right back to this plate I think you
could use it for a variety of things new
item up there uh how much you guys want
to pay for me to stick my socks in this
moron's mouth I will did football legend
Joe Theisman just bid a thousand dollars
to put a sock in my mouth you bet okay
but let's get it going a little honestly
back to the porno please uh 1200 bucks
I'd say 1300 would be even better 1300
Joe Theisman coming in storm I got 139
talking about thirteen hundred bucks Joe
Theisman can I stick the sock in his
mouth I'll pay extra yes you may because
I just sold my item to the man in the
gray shirt at table 18. NYPD you're
under arrest
[Music]
my leg you broke my other leg uh oh this
was supposed to be a safe event nothing
to see here except for the bone sticking
out of the legs Joe I videoed it hello
Mrs Obama
Grant how you doing
I'm good this is Leslie Knope she's
considering a job with us running the
new Midwest Bureau in Chicago well you
know how I feel about Chicago you are
from Chicago so you like it that's right
and we need passionate people like you
in our national parks you know they get
hundreds of millions of visitors each
year are you nodding because you agree
with me yes I do agree with you I agree
with you on all things throughout
history Until the End of Time Forever
you and Grant work together yeah we work
together a lot he's helped me integrate
the let's move program into our national
parks you know getting kids outside rock
climbing hiking well that's really
really incredible great work I'm sorry
I'm talking so loud I'm getting louder
now and I can't stop my apologies just
I don't know
high-fiving yeah well I hope you take
the job change happens one person at a
time
good to meet you
[Applause]
again
think it over
[Laughter]
oh
I'm gonna call you back a snitting next
to barpo
[Music]
Portland's got a fun little Waterfront
do you mind if I close this window shade
I'm trying to adopt a baby but my job is
making it impossible because my work
self is suffocating my life me I'm Liz
Lemon and I lost my virginity at 25. I
saw the show about following her fear
and it inspired me to wear shorts to
work it didn't go great do you know
I took a pill earlier but
I'm gonna get my September issue of a
magazine do you have the number for
subscription what
what I eat emotionally and one time at
summer camp I kissed a girl on a dare
but then she drowned here comes more
stuff I hate my feet and once I had a
sex dream about Nate burkus but halfway
through he turned into Dr Oz has that
ever happened to you a hug this is
happening it's all right Liz it's all
right uh I'm okay please stay close uh
can you keep your hands outside my
clothes okay I'm good
a lot of us women eat emotionally Liz
and while we're not always in control of
our feelings we do control the decisions
we make I know of course now you say
that you want a child and yet you let
Jenna and Tracy fill that role in your
life maybe you're afraid of taking that
next step oh my God that's it
now that we've leveled off and think
they're going to serve us a little snack
so
so wise you know when you say that to
everything
it makes me feel like you're not
listening sorry
here
wonderful saltwater taffy from Rhode
Island wow is this one of your favorite
things yes and I have so many wonderful
favorite things this year sweater capes
calypso music Paisley tops Chinese
checkers high-heeled flip-flops that
lift up your butt and give you a workout
and you
Liz Lemon
too many women are wearing themselves
too thin these days and what suffers
because of that you're about almost
personal life personal life yes I want
to help you
say please welcome
on no but here is what I will do while
I'm in New York if you want I can stop
by and I can talk to Tracy and Jenna
solve that little problem for you so you
can concentrate on Liz for once oh you
are the best person in the whole world
I am Leslie Knope I love this town and
I've worked my whole life to make it
great
I believe that I've earned your vote
Bobby Newport believes he can buy it and
maybe that's because he's never earned
anything his entire life
that I hurt my feelings hurt my feelings
there's supposed to be this positive
person can we just talk about things we
like
well so uh just a reminder to our
candidates to keep it civil
looking at you Leslie ah it's okay Joan
I'm okay I'm just
I'm nervous man I'm nervous I guess I
want to do a good job because I like it
when people think I do a good job and I
want your vote because I want Pawnee and
my dad to see what I'm made of
so let's do this
Wrecking Crew we let you guys in
hey Jason I guess my thoughts on
abortion are
you know let's just all have a good time
the conference room is ready if we want
to get started you know I just want to
address everyone first oh yeah take your
time Stanley pay attention hi everyone
hi
hi uh look it's no secret hi
hello uh it is no secret
that Michael Scott paper is siphoned off
a large chunk of our Core Business and
I'm here I just want to reassure
everyone that we think this is just a
temporary setback right okay maybe and I
don't know if you just returned
Michael's call none of us would have
lost clients I've been wondering that
myself lately we're just going to get
started we're going to figure this out
rest assured Jim can you come in with
this please oh Jim hold on no David oh
Dwight's been my guy okay yeah June
really I find that extraordinarily
surprising he shows promise and Jim I I
don't know I just been a disappointment
we'll bring them both okay great uh
Dwight come on in oh also Jim
come along after thought